today on stick to football we get you
ready for the weekend it's Friday the
13th and we were gonna run through
everything that's happening in college
football NFL NFL draft before picking
the week three college football games I
think it yes we're officially officially
top five Heisman candidates as well and
you can watch us on YouTube you can see
I just almost hugged Melo because it's
been a day I can barely walk but I'm
okay and Connors on the show too
Connor and I are gonna be hanging out in
New York actually New Jersey Monday
night so confusing
will be a lot 11 at 5:30 come get drunk
with this I need it it is gonna is gonna
be a hell of a we need a fun week I need
it we all need it
11 I do want to say before we get into
it there will not be a Monday morning
show and I know y'all are tired of us
jerking you around with the schedule I'm
sorry but there won't be a Monday show
it'll be Tuesday Wednesday Friday next
week we will eventually get back on a
normal schedule but tailgate tour means
we got to shuffle some things around so
no Monday show sleep in I don't listen
to that new Taylor Swift album on the
way to work I mean that's what I've been
doing same actually not bad it's not bad
it's not bad at all I kind of like it um
I want to ask you guys a question
and have you read in mono everybody on
the show yeah I've had it your time mono
haver is it mono if you've had a twice
its duo when you've had it twice I had
it I was 19 I think and as we were
talking Connor before we started
recording if you've ever dated a girl
from southeast Kansas but live in
southwest Missouri you've probably had
mono yeah I think the males in like
southeast Kansas are almost immune to it
by this point so all those guerrilla
fans that we have listening there you go
you know that already I actually when I
was in high school there are two rival
high schools not that we went to but
there are two rival high schools in
southeast Kansas one of them is called
Colgan st. Mary's their Catholic school
to private school and there's another
one called Frontenac Kansas - pretty
good football teams that are about what
10 miles apart probably and I actually
heard of a story of a girl who got mono
the week that they had to play each
other I don't know if it wasn't
intentional or not but I do know she got
mono and she
spread that to members of the rival
football team intentionally she
purposefully spread that mono to the
other team I don't know what's going on
up there in New Jersey with the Jets but
Connor maybe there's a conspiracy theory
maybe there's some lady up there so
Belichick oh it's gotta be yeah some
people think they dumped off to Marius
Thomas to the Jets with mono but all I
know is I'm safe I think I've already
had it and this sucks I mean it's pretty
awful news for the New York Jets when it
first came out it was hey you know Sam's
not gonna play Monday night I don't want
to go all doctor here but you guys know
this as well when I had mono it was in
the middle of lacrosse season
I felt fine after ten days you cannot
play contact sports for at least three
weeks because of your spleen when you
have mono so the Jets are a little lucky
in a sense that their Buy is week four
which is as early as it can be but Sam's
Arnold is gonna miss some time that's
more than Monday and it's gonna be the C
man show in New Jersey right now Trevor
Samia that's actually our dead friend
who used to be on the podcast that's how
he lost his spleen he had mono played in
a softball tournament spleen ruptured
just dangerous and then he dies like
eighteen years later so it was a slow
burn but you do have to be really really
careful with that because yeah I mean
like I said I had it right after high
school and they were like no like
intramural sports no basketball in the
weekends it really does take about two
weeks you feel wrastlin you're gonna die
no wrassling no tipping cows for me for
those two weeks it was brutal
you gotta like shut [ __ ] down for the
for amount of time Dean yeah I feel bad
for Sam I feel bad for us because we're
gonna be there to watch this game and
now we don't get to see Sam darn old I
guess the good news is levy on bail the
MRI on his shoulder came back negative
so we are gonna get to see him but I
mean like this whole Jets team is banged
up CJ Moseley left the game last week I
think what Quintin Williams was may be
limited in practice as well so yep jeez
yeah it's gonna be great I can't wait to
see here's the thing if the Browns don't
win this game against just a beat-up
Jets team in old googly-eyes it is bad
news for Freddie kitchens and I we might
see a mutiny if they don't win this game
I agree with you too and I will sad that
I won't be able to join you fellas up
there but I was obviously rooting for
the Jets B
of the opposing teams quarterback but I
was really looking forward to the
showdown and I think that I won't say
this is a rivalry but there's like
bitterness between these two fan bases
of our quarterbacks better I was really
looking forward to seeing these two guys
play absolutely sucks obviously Sam
Donald's health is more important to
this game but I really was looking
forward to these two guys doing it out
in New York yeah it definitely you know
puts a big damper on things obviously
Sam burse Baker again and in just the
fact that this is really a must-win game
for both teams and now you know the line
has jumped up to six and a half of the
Browns the Jets aren't even expected to
be in this game
I do think they'll come out with having
a check down like levy on helps
hopefully they'll keep it competitive I
think Greg Williams versus Odell Beckham
just got a lot more interesting right
now if you're looking for some kind of
reason to get invested in this game if
you need any more though we're gonna be
having a hell of a time in 11 so don't
dump off your tickets yet we're giving
you a reason to still come to the game
we're gonna have a blast I do think it's
gonna be one of our biggest and best
tailgates yet you're gonna want to see
what I'm wearing like you've already put
it all over social media I'm gonna baby
who don't follow me they're gonna want
to see what I'm wearing
yeah I actually had to order something
else that Jersey was too big never mind
then so a Trevor Simeon Jersey hopefully
that's what it's gonna be the one
winning quarterback of the starters the
vapor black Trevor Simeon Jersey and the
back awesome oh do they really make
those or would you have to set up some
custom order that I would just get a my
own name I get Maddy Mills on the back I
think you should for the JMU story it
would have been number 69 man yells can
we rush order one of those now maybe for
another time overnight it exactly uh but
I do want to talk about this they came
down the pike California god bless this
state they have decided that it's called
fair play
basically college athletes can now
profit off their likeness which is
something that we've really been
advocating for that's the word I was
looking for from now two and a half
years as long as this podcast has been
around in California student-athletes
can now do this which i think is
incredible and calling it fair play is
important because it is about
this is the most fair way in my opinion
for college athletes to profit off their
skillset if you are USC or UCLA or
Stanford this is a really gonna help
with recruiting but hopefully what this
does this really starts a ripple effect
across the country where we will see
conferences maybe even other states
follow suit I think this leads to not
only hopefully a little bit more parity
in college football because if you say
your rondell more and you're at Purdue
produce out a very good school but
you're the guy and you are electric
there and everyone knows who you are you
have a chance to even now make more
money as the star for Purdue than you
would as another guy on Alabama or
another guy Ohio State so I could even
see this helping with parity but most
importantly this could help us get
college football back as a video game
yeah obviously I think when everybody
sees that news come across the wire that
this is going down I think that's the
first thought as oh my gosh can we get
this college football game back because
that's what I'm interested in but I am
curious to see what these other
conferences do now
obviously the pac-12 is gonna be very
affected by it but how is this going to
affect the big 12 and SEC as well
because the SEC is not going to sit
around and say wait
we're losing guys from Texas Louisiana
Florida and they're all going out to
California now where they can get paid I
think it'll be very quick before we
start to see guys like Nick Saban
calling up there they're members of
Congress and saying we need to get
something done here calling your
politicians trying to get this done in
other states because the people in Texas
aren't gonna like it either you get
these kids from Texas leaving to go to
UCLA it's gonna be a big deal they want
to keep them at home I want to see what
they can do with these other conferences
I absolutely love it and I think it's
going to force change from the NCAA they
have to change now they're going to have
to adapt to what they've been doing for
the last couple years and it's just not
working
nobody's happy with it so good for the
state of California then they're finally
coming through and and actually looking
out for their players and in response to
that isn't the n-c-double-a trying to
block it now they are a [ __ ] and that's
got to be part of it besides the fact
that they're just demons but when it
comes down to it this will be a pretty
long drawn-out probably process but it's
a step in the right direction for
something that's so long overdue and
obviously on this show we're
very excited about the aspect of
n-c-double-a football coming back to any
console but also just the fact that like
remember a couple years ago the kicker
that had a youtube channel that was
successful a walk away from football
that's like out that's just [ __ ] is
what it comes down to and this is
definitely it California is getting the
wheels going in motion here for
something that hopefully in a couple of
years will be nationwide yeah and that's
one more thing about it is it's not like
the schools are coming out and they're
playing these players that's tough to
say it's going to be money that they're
making from like a YouTube channel or
exactly or going now even look at it
from not a football point of view these
other kids like to a volleyball player
going out and hosting a summer event now
she can go get paid a couple extra
dollars based on what she's doing or or
you see some of these other people come
home a baseball player helping out at a
hitting facility you can throw a couple
of dollars his way now for coming and
helping out or football players to
signing an autograph being used in a
video game that's going to make millions
if not billions of dollars well as soon
as it comes back you're just throwing a
little money their way for them being
them that's it no schools recruiting and
saying we're gonna pay you this much
money so I love this plan and I at least
want to see how it shakes out if it's
not good if it's affecting recruiting
and it seems a little scummy then you
know what we can go and we can make
changes but we need to try something new
at least for now that's why I think
everyone's like oh this isn't a great
final solution okay well it's a step in
the right direction at least of figuring
some of this out like Melo just said
okay if there if there are holes we'll
change them but this is we can adapt we
could be flexible but something needs to
happen one thing I do want to get to
guys some some Marcus gosh-darn I cannot
talk today some major injuries happening
in the world of college well there
really is gonna affect the 2020 NFL
Draft
Stanford left tackle Walker little is
gonna miss the rest of the year with a
knee injury he was seen by many as a
potential first-round pick a Purdue
linebacker Marcus Bailey I thought he
was the best senior linebacker in the
country behind Isaiah Simmons he is now
out for the over the knee injury
Jake Bentley out for the year South
Carolina a quarterback was I believe a
foot injury so three names two of them
really good one of them plays
quarterback who are out for the year now
and that's really gonna shake things up
Walker little
it's early enough in the year we could
see him maybe still enter the draft
Marcus Bailey can actually apply for a
sixth year of eligibility if he would
like to and the same with Jake Bentley
he's a senior but he could use a medical
redshirt because he played as a true
freshman right and he was already a
young guy he like reclassified or
whatever it's called so I wouldn't be
surprised to see Marcus Bailey and Jake
Bentley both coming back next year to
see what they can do with Walker little
I don't know if we'll see him and
Stanford uniform again I could see him
recovering from this and saying you know
what I'm gonna go ahead test the draft
waters and see what happens
he was very high on people's board I
think he would at least be in that
second to third round so it will be
interesting to see what he does if he
doesn't like to come back to Stanford
but hopefully all three of these guys do
recover well and they all get healthy
yeah on a college football scale these
injuries are huge on the draft scope you
look at Walker little like you guys just
said and it definitely flips things
upside down a little bit I feel like all
of us on the show acknowledged over
summer he had a long ways to go in terms
of developing but in terms of tools and
raw traits he had it all and had a
chance truly to get into the top 30
picks top 20 picks next year so I'll
keep an eye on what he's gonna do the
demand on offensive lineman even raw
offensive lineman at tackle has been as
high as ever in the NFL he'll have to
wait and see what kind of feedback he
gets from the advisory board how his
recovery comes along but that's
definitely the one to highlight from
this group wildly popular segment that
we did last week is called blind kill
recap melo got nothing right last week
not even the location no it was
absolutely terrible I'm going to try to
do a better job this week and we did
have one person tweeting at me those I
was so confused when I listened to this
segment I thought it was funny but I had
no idea what was going on right now we
are recording this it is 4:30 Central
Time on Thursday we have not watched
Thursday Night Football yet but I don't
think that that's an excuse on a reason
why we shouldn't cover the game it's
very important it's the only NFL game
out right now we have to talk about it
and let me tell you Matt Connor very
impressed with Christian McCaffrey I
think that he is the running back that
we all thought he was going to be very
high
I draft pick and it's starting to show
off how they're using him in the past
game using him as a check down splitting
him out wide still very impressive game
I think he got almost 100 yards rushing
if not more and obviously the touchdown
was exceptional as well and I think
there's still a lot of question marks
around this Tampa Bay team where I just
don't know if they're gonna get it done
obviously Jameis Winston had a terrible
game surprise so bad I think that maybe
we even have to have a quarterback
change here great game I'm glad that we
got to watch it very impressed with
Christian McCaffrey 4 on my part Melo
going out on a limb here on the blind
recap hears that I'll say I think Brian
Burns is making a statement as let's go
potential Defensive Rookie of the Year
candidate we saw it throughout the
preseason
I know it's Tampa Bay and we saw them
really struggle last week to slow down
Nick Boston the San Francisco 49ers but
Brian burns the technique the speed off
the edge went the spin move that he put
on the right tackle and then just
crushed Lee Jameis elite you see the
flashes there and I'll say I'm gonna
echo up Melo said Jameis Winston another
double turnover game it's time to get
this guy off the field yeah and I looked
at this game and I thought Donovan Smith
made a statement as well because he got
away with highway robbery recently when
he got that 41 and a half million dollar
deal he got smoked in this one got his
quarterback killed again Christian
McCaffrey I you said it already Melo but
eight catches over 150 all-purpose yards
yeah easy easy cover for Carolina in
this one week three of college football
is here I'm gonna continually mess this
up because it is this segment too and my
brain just sees the two and thinks it's
week two its week three college football
review I was terrible last week terrible
good I got one game right on the pick'm
so I need to rebound this week I lost a
hundred bucks on Syracuse
I didn't pick a game right basically so
this week I'm back Melo is at ten and
five Connors at three and two I am gonna
get fired from my own show I'm seven and
eight let's start here guys number
twenty Washington State - ten at Houston
the over-under is a whopping 74 and I'm
gonna tell you to take the over yeah I
say that you gotta take the over it's
Mike Leach and Dana Holgorsen they might
score 150 not really but they're gonna
score I think
100 they definitely could I am taking
Washington State Houston just cannot
play defense
yeah I'm agreeing with you two and I
want to see what Washington state can do
because people have been in my mentions
of not giving them enough credit it's
nothing personal you're breaking in a
new quarterback every year now it seems
like so it takes a little bit of time to
really figure out what Washington State
has I do think that they have enough to
beat Houston Houston kind of
disappointing really I thought they
would come out and start the season a
lot better than what they did I didn't
expect a win against Oklahoma but I
expected a lot of points and if you
struggle to put up points against that
Oklahoma defense usually that's not a
good sign so we'll see what they can do
I do expect them to hit the over in this
if it said it at 74 I'd go ahead and hit
that over yeah if we were talking about
the spread in this one I feel a little
bit more conflicted but I think
Washington State is just gonna win this
game and it there's not gonna be not a
defense had in this matchup boys no and
hey by the way speaking of Washington
State how about our Guy Gardner Minshew
I'm so happy for this dude's awesome I
know I know they lost to the Chiefs last
week but I am all you know I hope
Gardner Minshew Wally pips Nick Foles I
don't everything against Nick Foles I
just want Gardner men should be a
starting quarterback in the I would like
that story as well cuz I don't know him
but he seems like such a good guy and
then coming in and talking about the
backup Dobbs and like no I'm not even in
the same room as this guy he's so smart
I'd like him as a personality I think
I'm sorry that I didn't get to spend
time with him at the Senior Bowl like he
looks like a fun fella he absolutely
does number 24 USC I think the surprise
of last week maybe over the last two
weeks is USC there - for at BYU the over
unders forty eight and a half the that
over/under I might go under on I know us
he's got this young quarterback Tova's
Clovis Lovis I was close great freshman
looks great he's been lighting it up BYU
bronco mendenhall defenses are
traditionally pretty pretty strong this
could be a tough place to play so I
would maybe go under on this one but I
do think that USC wins and I think they
cover that - for yeah I'm gonna agree
with you I do think USC wins but I do
think that there's still just so much
going on at UC it USC it's gonna be
tough for them to go into BYU and win
this game so
setting it at minus 4 for us see that's
such a tough number to play with because
I do think that this game is gonna be
close it won't get much worse than that
so I'm gonna take USC out right and as
far as the over-under goes I'm gonna
take the over just because I think USC
can put up points again they put up
points against Stanford that looked
impressive so I think that they can
probably get the job done against BYU as
well I know we were hard on this Trojans
team a little bit over the summer but
there are things that I really like
about them right now one being their
corner Elijah Griffin that is Warren G's
son he's awesome awesome defensive back
very young corner
obviously slovis now flashing a
quarterback they have good wide
receivers I like USC in this game as
well and things are trending up finally
for the Trojans I know it's early but
things still look good at least you know
say BYU barely beat Tennessee it took an
overtime last week so I know Tennessee's
had a right season I know I don't need
another bad review Tennessee's had a
rough start to the season maybe that's
where we start to see the volunteers
build some confidence to get back in
there I like Jeromy Pruitt I'd love to
see him get that turned around you guys
mentioned Stanford losing last week to
USC they are at number seventeen UCF
this the Knights - seven over unders 55
and a half I'm gonna take UCF Stanford
is so beat up KJ Costello should be back
this week but he's been hurt we Mitchell
Walker littles out the Stanford defense
just looks absolutely terrible and I
this is kind of funny because I've been
baking UCF like play somebody just
please play somebody then finally doing
they get like the worst Stanford team in
ten years yeah I agree with you and with
the Walker little news I think that
really changes things - we'll see what
KJ castello can do if he is in there I
wasn't not impressed by what he was able
to do against Northwestern
so I'm going to agree with you I hate
when we do this Matt but three for three
here at Green with you I'm gonna take
UCF as well I think that traveling is
going to be a big difference maker going
from Palo Alto all the way to Florida
that time zone it almost killed me going
to Vegas and that is not a big don't
rule out the humidity here yeah and the
humidity I don't know if they're gonna
be used to that so I I do like UCF for
all the other reasons and I think that
they are probably better on the field -
I want to see what Brandon Wimbush can
do I like him in this offense they've
been putting up points against nobodies
now they get
somewhat of a test I guess a little bit
more of a test against Stanford but I'm
gonna take UCF and I'm going to take the
under I'm disappointed in you guys
because this show has you know been
harsh on UCF for some time and we
finally get a chance to pick against
them I'm going with Stanford
I know a lead-up I know UCF has an
offense that should easily out score the
Stanford team I just think they were
gonna get bullied in this one if I'm
wrong I'm wrong I think this is gonna be
a shock to them though when they see
those big boys the style of football
that Stanford plays I like the upset in
this game I mean I don't feel great
about betting on Brandon Wimbush if even
plays I've watched enough of him I just
I don't think he'll be able to throw
against Stanford and do not throw it
against the des Beaux yeah don't even
look his direct France Island out there
number 19 Iowa - won at Iowa State the
over-under on this one is 47 they're
expecting a little bit of a heavyweight
bout in this one guys I'm gonna take the
hawk ice even on the road
I think Iowa State is just behind
they're down this year you lose David
Montgomery you lose the key Butler they
haven't replaced those guys that well
everyone knows my love for Maddy
Campbell I mean he's a fantastic coach I
think he'll be an NFL head coach soon he
might be head coach of the Browns next
year the way things are going but I just
don't feel like that they are talented
enough to compete with this Iowa
teammate Stanley has been on a tear the
last five games something we really
haven't spent enough time talking about
but I think having the week off I know
Iowa State barely beat Northern Iowa in
the opener they have the week off
I think Iowa comes into this one really
ready to go and they win this state
rivalry I don't think so Matt I'm going
with Iowa State in this one and this is
my super underdog locksmith game of the
week to bet your money on because I
don't have the nuts to bet my own money
on I like this underdog at Iowa State
this is going to be a heated rivalry and
looking at these two teams coming into
this season
I liked Iowa State more I like what they
can do at home yeah I know they almost
lost to Northern Iowa I think that's all
behind them now I love this defense I
love the players that they have at every
level I think that they can neutralize
Nate Stanley it can't be that hard we
saw a ton of teams do it last year you
don't have the targets too tight in like
they had before
I think that if you can keep a jf Anessa
away from Brock Purdy which is going to
be difficult but I think it's doable
I think Iowa State can win this game man
I'm a big Maddy Campbell fan I want Iowa
State to win this game I don't think it
happens I think the Hawkeye is win this
game in the trenches I think epinephrine
smake errs in this game I just think
he's gonna be a pest for that Iowa State
passing attack for the run game the
entire time also call me crazy 47 seems
a little high of a number I think I'd be
very scrappy against yeah yeah two teams
are first the 20 might win this one Melo
disrespecting Nate Stanley watch him go
off for like two touchdowns in this - 24
at Syracuse over/under sixty three and a
half Syracuse almost beat Clemson last
year they got their asses kicked last
week by Maryland I lost some money on it
not real happy also lost a lot of
respect for Dino Babers ability as a
coach while gaining a ton from
Maryland's offense which is unstoppable
with Josh Jackson and little booger
mcFarland Clemson is gonna win this game
little book that's his nickname it just
has to be Clemson is gonna win this game
boys I'm gonna take the over
and I think Clemson covers - 20 for this
this one's tough it was a game that I
was kind of highlighting all year
because I thought that Syracuse was
gonna be good I turned out on the
bandwagon and they absolutely got your
destroyed by an arrant exactly so I'm
going to take Clemson because I think
that's the obvious win here but I also
haven't been that impressed with what
clemson has been doing they they put up
24 points against A&M I was not
impressed by any of the performances
there that Saturday 52 on Georgia Tech
thank God for Travis etn because he did
everything for them
so I don't think that clemson is going
to cover but I do think they are going
to win as far as the over/under
I'm just not feeling great about these
offenses after last week so I'd probably
take the under as well yeah I'm going
Clemson all the way I think that they
have a shot to cover here I know that
line is fat but I'm going with Clemson
as well another fat line that I wanted
to throw in here
I got Ohio State favored by 16 against
Indiana
I think they easily smashed that cover
so some really really big lines this
week boys but when you look at this
Clemens
team after seeing what Marilyn did the
Cuse Clemson has no excuse not to at
least do the same at least I got Andre
Cisco had a pic that makes me feel a
little bit better and I'll throw this
note out before we go to break and come
back with our top five highest made
candidates there is not one game this
weekend that is a top 25 matchup when
that happens there's usually an upset so
I'm going to keep an eye on this weekend
I know that's ominous maybe as Iowa
State on the super underdog locksmith
game of the week to bet your money on
because Melo doesn't have the nuts to
bet his own money on guys it is Heisman
time we have put off talking about this
and so we got a couple weeks under our
belts but now we are going to give you
our top five Heisman candidates Melo
kick us off buddy and I I'm gonna start
with I think the guy who's gonna win the
Heisman at the end of the year yeah I
don't like to say it but it's Jalen
hurts what he's doing the way that he's
performing on the field and off of the
field I really like him I have never in
my life liked an Oklahoma quarterback
Jalen Hertz is the guy I love him I wish
him all the success this year and I
think that he's going to do it obviously
Lincoln Reilly's gonna help him put up
the numbers Oklahoma is gonna be in a
position to be one of the top teams
he plays quarterback he just fits the
formula he's going to do it if it's not
him obviously I think you have to talk
about to a who's also having an
exceptional year who actually looks
healthy this year scrambling last week
getting the ball out to these
exceptional receivers that's a
no-brainer tool we'll be in New York
the folks at Alabama go ahead and booked
his ticket he will be there for me he's
number two number three I still like
Jonathan Taylor I was on him all year
last year trying to get him to New York
this guy is going to rush for almost
2000 yards he's done everything for
Wisconsin this year catching the ball
out of the backfield carrying it well
rushing for about a hundred yards every
game I really like him and I want to see
Wisconsin play well I can't wait to see
them on the tailgate tour with Jonathan
Taylor the next quarterback I'm just
picking anti Texas guys right here this
goes to show that my unbiased opinion
does come through sometimes jobber oh
like you guys mentioned he looks amazing
this is not the same Joe burrow that I
saw I don't know what happened when he
got hit during that bowl game but it
turned him into a damn good
he's spider bite version of yes that's
the it's working for him
I like jobber and I think he's a guy
that we have to talk about as a draft
prospect as a Heisman candidate I know
our buddy Adam Heisler was even saying
that he's kind of fitting into this
Baker Mayfield mode this is coming out
of nowhere
gonna rise to the top with the swagger
similar personality he's starting to get
a little bit more comfortable and I
think just like Baker Mayfield it took a
year now he's in year two and we're
gonna start to see Joe Burrell kind of
come out of his shell because he's a
damn good quarterback he's performing
very well and the last guy I got to get
one of our defense four Heisman guys on
you and for me it's chase young if
you're gonna have one of these guys do
it and I'm leaving off Justin fields who
I think could be up there as well but I
think at Ohio State I would like to see
chase Young at least get some
recognition and get some other people
talking obviously it's just been too
long since we've had a guy even
considered for the defense for Heisman
thing so we have to make it happen it's
just been too long
chase Young's playing - well I had to
give him a shout-out I love that pick
mellow because I think if you're going
with the defender in the country right
now it's it really is chase young right
now he's been dominant he's gonna have
the sack numbers as we always try to
keep defense for Heisman going you need
production and he's got that my list
starts off with somebody that is on his
team that would be first year starting
quarterback Justin fields I just think
when we do this Heisman list some of it
is about projecting and I think Ohio
State's gonna be in the playoff
I think Fields is gonna be a big part of
that I think you look at the numbers
Haskins put up in this offense last year
I think fields can match that and his
ability as a runner might get him over
the top everything we've seen from him
and he's got the pro traits we're gonna
get that into that next year when he's
draft eligible but right now as a
college quarterback in Ryan daze offense
fields has been overwhelmingly
impressive and I know the competition
hasn't been great but I don't think his
play is gonna dial back once they play
good teams so and he's got a lot of
round him to make it happen
jaylen hurts number two once again the
stats are gonna be there he plays in the
big 12 he looks a lot better a lot more
comfortable as a passer already in
Lincoln Reilly's offense and Oklahoma is
one of those teams that's expected to
be in the playoff hunt where he's going
to be under consideration number three
and these guys are all grouped together
one two and three there's really no it's
1a 1b 1c 2 a tongue of AI Lowa something
that all three of us talked about a lot
over the summer there's gonna be a
feeling amongst voters that to a kind of
got robbed last year where by losing it
right at the end of the season and if
it's a tie between all these guys at the
end of the year I think by default it'll
be handed to tua he is throwing to
players like Judy Ann drugs he has a
great line but to is a great football
player and if you're looking for you
know a headliner from Alabama who should
not lose any games of course it's to a
rondelle Moore is number four for me and
this is one of them we have to start
talking about this one he leads the
country and receptions already he is his
team's offense he's a phenomenal
receiver he's a true sophomore the speed
the strength the production he's a go to
kind of target now will he get invited
to the Heisman ceremony at the end of
the year I don't know because you always
have to be on a winning kind of team
that's how it goes but if we're just
talking about the best player in college
football the most productive player in
college football you have to have
rondell Moore in that conversation it's
as simple as that for me number five and
you talked about this Mello Matt I know
you talked about him very highly not as
just as a draft prospect this week but
also as a college player Joe burrow the
steps he's taken he looks like a
completely different quarterback in this
offense he's not just managing the
offense he's a playmaker in that LSU
offense this year
yeah and I'll tell you man I doing a lot
of phone calls this week talking about
quarterbacks and the Joe burrow love is
real out there I like to say yeah this
could be a baker like rice it really
could be I'm so excited to see him when
we get to the Senior Bowl I assume that
we will be seeing him there tops on my
list guys and I will say this is who I
think should win not who will because I
could actually see voters having a
backlash against to up because like oh
well he has Jerry Judy and he has Henry
rugs and he has all this talent around
him vide it's kind of like why does Tom
Brady only have what like three MVPs or
why did why does LeBron not win it every
year back during his amazing run you
just kind of get tired of people being
good and I think the voters could
actually revolt against that a little
bit I personally think they did
they were looking for two ative slip so
someone else could win it not to take
anything away from Kyler Murray but two
of this year has just been frankly
unstoppable 66% completion percentage
last week he sit over 75 on the Year
seven touchdowns passing one rushing no
turnovers - it just looks unstoppable
again so he's tops on my list Jalen
Hertz is at number two
I know Melo said this earlier in the
show I love Jalen hurt so much off the
field that I think it almost impacts how
I view him on it because he's such a
great leader and the character so good
and he's just he's solid and he's
playing so loose and relaxed six passing
touchdowns no interceptions so far we're
seeing him really get involved on the
ground as well he's already got three
rushing touchdowns so we could see a 50
touchdown season from Jalen Hurst which
would win him the Heisman in my opinion
you know regardless of what we see guys
like to hit do so Jalen hurts way way up
there and what helps him like we're
gonna see - we'll play Georgia we're
gonna see to play Alabama Auburn
Mississippi State he's gonna play some
really good teams Jalen hurts ain't
playing nobody and I will throw my Texas
Longhorns under the bus on that take
those [ __ ] shirts off you can't cover
and you can't tackle Jalen hurts ain't
playing anybody tell the college
football playoff so that's only gonna
boost his numbers that's gonna help
number three this is where I have Justin
fields I have been so impressed by his
performance I think you got to tip the
hat a little bit to Ryan day - Brian
Hartline the wide receivers coach there
this is a team that lost Parris Campbell
they lost Mike Weber they lost Gary
Terry they lost some big talent and now
they just turned in oh we got a new
quarterback
we got three new starting receivers
we're fine dude right now is completing
76 percent of his passes six touchdowns
no interceptions and they haven't played
terrible team Cincinnati's not a bad
team kind of like we were saying with -
like we're gonna see Justin fields
challenged a little bit with in his
conference so that will maybe make or
break him but Dewayne Haskins threw for
50 touchdowns last year and I think
fields is gonna be on a pace to do that
means six passing three rushing already
and he's gonna run two games so that's
gonna help him out and they're gonna
probably be undefeated that's a huge key
here for me number four in the list it
is our guy Jonathan Taylor
he hasn't had the huge rushing games yet
I mean he busted up for 135 against
South Florida only 102 against Central
Michigan but the key here is he already
has eight touchdowns because he is
getting involved more in the passing
game his three receiving touchdowns so I
can see Jonathan Taylor having easily a
25 28 touchdown season when it comes to
all-purpose yardage and I do think you
know he has added 20 carry game yet I
think we'll see his carries really
uptick maybe even you know this weekend
Wisconsin's off and then we're at their
game against Michigan I can see him
having a big carry game coming off a bye
so I would expect if Jonathan Taylor
goes for like 250 against Michigan and
he could I mean Michigan's defense it's
pretty weak so far this year I think
that puts him on the national stage and
then number five on my list I'm going
all offense guys it is Joe burrow when
you tear up Texas like burrow did you're
on the radar and like you guys said he
has been nearly flawless the last three
games we've seen him play going back to
that UCF ballgame he didn't have the one
pick against Texas but still to rally
that team to win as long as LSU remains
a top five team
I think burrow has a chance to get his
name called and the bad thing about
doing top five is they're guys that
thought I had to leave out like Travis
etn is saving clemson season right now
arguably Trevor Lawrence has not played
that well t Higgins has been fine Justin
Ross has been fine but it's a whole
Travis ETN Rhonda Moore was a great one
chase young I'm so glad you put him up
there
I really thought last year Josh Allen
should have got been invited to New York
with the stats he had maybe chase young
gets the invite this year if he's on a
good enough team draft on draft on boys
and a question from I believe this
person has never asked before I think
it's poncey Calif a I'm saying that
right it looks right looks right which
young quarterback are you taking to have
a better all-around college career and
we're going really young here Spencer
Sanders or Brock party I know Spencer
Sanders his Melos guy I am actually
going to echo that as well I assume that
you're gonna yeah I'm taking Spencer
Sanders yeah I really like him and I he
didn't get the chance last year he
redshirted but they you know they had
the quarterback that was there in place
for a very long time I'm excited to see
what Mike Gundy can do with Spencer
Sanders I think he's a very good athlete
in this spread system and first
some reason Gundy hasn't been pulling in
athletes at quarterback
they've been these tall standing in the
pocket type guys like you
now Rudolph was there forever it seems
like I want to see what Spencer Sanders
and Mike Gundy can do once they team up
and we really get things going because
he is still young
I like Brock Purdy I don't know he
doesn't Wow me there there are no trades
there early in his career that make me
say that this guy's gonna be something
special I think he's gonna be one of
those quarterbacks who starts for four
years he's gonna have a shitload of wins
under his belt but I don't think he's
gonna do anything that really Wow's me
Spencer Sanders I think that he will I
think he will very soon yeah I think in
that system Sanders will have more
production will be the more exciting
player I do agree with you Melo that
Purdy's one of those guys that might be
a longtime starter and you you know walk
away from his career and you look and
you go wow he won a lot of games but I
think there's a lot more excitement
around Sanders ability and what he can
do in their offense I like sander and
like Melo said it's so great to see
Oklahoma State open things up a little
bit you know we've seen him run the ball
more I think against Oregon State he had
over a hundred yards rushing he has six
sessions that you're know picks and he
and Thailand Wallace have a really nice
connection going so I would pick Spencer
Sanders and he's another guy like when
we see them play Oklahoma see them play
Texas he's gonna put up big numbers see
them play West Virginia he's gonna put
up a really really big number so I'm
with you on Spencer Sanders Mike Hubbard
with this circus show of tanking in
Miami going on what are the chances to
assess bucket I'm not playing in Miami
who is not that kind of guy no he's not
he's not he'll just go back to school if
he feels that way exactly that's what I
think I don't think that he would ever
come out and be like you know what I'm
not going to Miami anybody else can
draft me I think that he would see oh
the Dolphins have the first pick no I'm
good here with Nick Saban I'll go win
another national championship and if he
doesn't get the Heisman he would
definitely be the front-runner going
into that next season you guys have
heard me say this there's so many times
and this was my thing about Baker it was
one of the my favorite things about
Baker Mayfield was there were reports
that like Josh Rosen didn't want to go
to the Browns and maybe Sam Darnell
didn't want to go to the Browns but
Baker was like I'll go to the Browns
I'll turn it around like I'll fix the
Browns please draft me like I got you
and I can almost see - is not that loud
but I can see him having the confidence
of you have the Dolphins want to draft
me like I'll just go there would be a
great leader and a great team integrator
back and all they'll build a [ __ ]
statue of me oh I'll take Dan Marino's
13 and wear it like I don't care so I
think that's one thing like to a is a
little he's understated but I think he's
confident enough so it's that
double-edged sword
just remember only one time we've two
times we've really seen quarterbacks say
I don't want to play there and that was
John Elway that was Eli Manning yeah
like there bits of quarterbacks drafted
his shitty situations Jared Goff had to
play for Jeff Fisher guys and he didn't
say anything so I think more often than
not we are gonna see guys like to have
the confidence in themselves to say I
can turn this around and I actually it
would it would bother me as an evaluator
if ii was like no i don't want to go to
Miami like why like why not his dad
stepping in like with the Manning
situation his dad has a lot of control
his dad decided where he went to play
college ball I believe clearly you know
I had it yeah had a very big say in it
so I don't know that we would see it
from tool but I really wouldn't be
surprised if his dad started making a
little bit noise more noise once it does
come time for draft season I think when
it comes down to it yeah it's as simple
as if he doesn't want to go there he'll
just go back to school it's as simple as
that and we don't even know if he'll be
picked over
you know Herbert or I mean that's really
probably what it's gonna come down to
him Herbert unless you know shock you
know somebody shocks the world let's
take quarterback the Dolphins don't say
quarterback which they will I think when
it comes down to it though it too is
just not that kind of guy we haven't had
I just I'm looking like thinking of it
in a while it's hard to project somebody
like you know Trevor Lawrence won't be
like that when that time comes he'll go
play wherever he's just justin fields
won't be like that i don't think i think
he'll go play wherever it's a very rare
Jay Grubbs not there oh hey oh my god
yeah when it comes down to it guys just
get your after then they go and if they
are nervous about that and have
eligibility they go back to school I
don't even think Eli I don't think 22
year old Eli was like no I don't want to
play for the child not at all that's
Archie being like hey know which
and he has won two Super Bowl so that's
that's a whole rabble whole week you
could add Dakota Cox wants to know what
are the odds that Alabama LSU game will
be a matchup of unbeaten teams by the
time November rolls around we will be at
this game so I selfishly hope that it is
two unbeaten teams but guys
LSU schedule is really really tough it's
insane nobody is their home against
Florida who's a top 10 team right now
and their home against Auburn who's a
top 10 team right now right but holy
[ __ ] it's not even just those games
Vandy Vandy has not been good but van
Dee's a little bit scary because they
have some guys on offense
Utah State has my dude Jordan love out
there just slinging bullets like you
said there's the Florida game reveled in
this obviously it's not easy going to
Mississippi State Auburn comes to town
this schedule that is tough man it
I love coach oh I think he's hilarious
think he's an underrated coach obviously
Brady their offensive coordinators doing
some amazing things but this is a bit of
a murderous row in Alabama is playing
like nobody dares to play Tennessee
I don't think both these teams will be
undefeated when we go to see them in
November I definitely think that they
can handle it only Am's tripping up and
I think obviously Alabama is gonna run
the table and I think pretty easily they
faced Arkansas the week before LSU they
got Tennessee on that schedule Ole Miss
on their lookout for Southern Miss they
might you know disrupt some things but
if they can they have to get through
Texas A&M and that's it and we just saw
Clemson do it so I think Alabama can do
it as well LSU you're right they do have
some more tests but I still I think they
can get it done right they host Florida
like Connor said they get Auburn at home
the only thing that would worry me is if
they're looking at that Auburn game and
they're looking ahead to Alabama
they've been tripped up before in
situations like that with Coach o so if
they can get through that Alabama or
sorry not looking ahead to Alabama I
think they'll be fine
I think they're a better football team
than Auburn I just worry about them
worrying too much about Alabama do you
think maybe I I don't I'm not trying to
piss off LSU fans because that was a
great great game and it was a great win
I mean they've beaten Georgia Southern
and an overrated Texas team I think we
need to see them play somebody yeah I
agree because obviously I
pointed out the fact that that Texas
defense is not good not good you can
wear whatever t-shirt you want but when
you're not playing well it doesn't
matter I do think that this is a good
football team though to put up that many
passing yards against a talented team
even though they are under overrated is
different but I like what I'm seeing so
far out of LSU because they haven't
really asked they haven't got much out
of their defense yet and there are a lot
of players on that team that need to
show up need to see Chaisson do a little
bit more than what he did against Texas
and I think it eventually they'll get
things taking their I wouldn't overlook
Florida for them I do think that Florida
is still pretty good even if they can
just overcome their quarterback that's a
good football team but I do think and
expect and hope that both of these teams
will be undefeated when we see them on
November 9th alright Ben Monte Morris
who's your favorite coach of all time
college or professional and why I don't
know how many people know this about me
I think a lot of folks would expect me
to say Bill Walsh is my favorite coach
of all time and he was like growing up I
wanted to be Bill Walsh that was my life
goal Bill Belichick is my favorite coach
of all time I love the way and I tweeted
about this during the game the other
night I know kind of sorry I love the
Patriots philosophy of okay like let's
just look at their backfield to have
Sony Michele to have James White never X
Birkhead and a half Devlin the full-back
each of those guys has a very specific
role a thing that they're really good at
the Patriots look at James White and say
you're not that great of a runner but
you can catch the ball really well
you're a good route runner and you can
match a ball gets linebackers will throw
the ball to you 18 times the game in the
Super Bowl if we have to and we'll win
the [ __ ] game so I love that
Belichick the greatest coach of all time
he could sit up on his little ivory
tower and say I'm what guys who do this
but instead he which is true scouting
says okay what does Rex Burkhead do well
I'm going to put him in a position to do
that
what is Julian Edelman do well what do
all these just role players that you
know guys like their offensive line how
many of those guys start for anyone else
not many like they had like a that
they're sinner sucked so bad the other
night then I can snap the ball faster
probably and they still they scored 33
points on the Steelers like
Bella checks ability to just put people
in situations to excel is I've never
seen anything like it yeah I mean you
went on like a five minute rant there
about Bella chicks so there's that one
I was gonna say Mack Brown just because
he brought the championship to my team
but you're just a Mack Brown hater I
would almost I would call you a traitor
he is responsible for everything that
Texas has every single thing because
they were a dog [ __ ] when he got there
they had Ricky Williams and Ricky
Williams probably wouldn't have made it
to his junior season without Mack Brown
there
so anything that Texas has done recently
was with Mack Brown they didn't do [ __ ]
with Charlie Strong they haven't done
[ __ ] with Tom Herman yet Mack Brown is
the guy attack thanks Finch yes
Thank You Benjamin he was there for a
little bit too long but still he brought
in Vince he got the best out of gonna
see us get mad at each other is that's
the only thing that we got mad about is
Mack Brown cuz I look at this screen get
ready for a fight or some last one yeah
I just don't like Mack Brown I mean I
love him like if he were my grandfather
would be awesome but I got he was just
so bad there at the end I mean I don't
really have a favorite coach because
none of the rich coach ight yeah that's
my favorite that's a great one man I
mean I really like like I read about
coaches I really like Bill Parcells and
just the Parcells tree and he's coached
everywhere obviously the most success of
the Giants but he coached the Jets had a
brief turnaround for the Jets honestly
my favorite Jets coach would and this
was very short-lived but I thought he
was the best drafting mind was Eric
Mangini
all of the players that Rex won with
were Man genies players that's the big
one for me I think right now my favorite
coach I know this is cliche but I think
we loved him as soon as he started
coaching is Sean McVeigh I just think
his personality his ability to you know
connect with players obviously he's one
of the brightest offensive minds we've
seen and yeah he lost in the Superbowl
but the guy is in his early 30s I mean
come on so I think we're all said and
done I think Sean McVeigh will go down
as probably my favorite coach that we've
watched in this era this is a little bit
off
topic is it hard as a Jets fan let's go
see like Pete Carroll and Bill Belichick
we're both the head coach of your team
and they've gone on to win Super Bowls
elsewhere and be like in the last 15
years to the greatest coaches in the NFL
and the just hilarious it's absolutely
hilarious I'm sure what how I was poking
I know I know oh I don't care people
always are like that with me and I feel
like you to know it more than anyone
like I don't like care about Jets jokes
or anything because it's they're all
true and hilarious it's like what like
stereotypes like I didn't want them to
hire Adam GaSe but I have to sit here
and watch that I wanted Todd Monken who
I think can be a Pete Carril a guy that
in his very very late stage of his
career is creative and energetic and fun
and now he's buried behind a guy that is
way in over his head and Cleveland and
Freddie kitchens it's not even gay
Cleveland before long I'm sorry Browns
fans if you don't want to hear that but
Baker Mayfield hired Freddie kitchens
John Dorsey should have hired the coach
so anyways
Connors gonna get them all riled up
before this tailgate I know not like me
right now cuz I made the Trevor Simeon
Baker Mayfield joke which was a joke
joke joke that's Trevor's 13 11 Baker's
six and eight or whatever it is I'm
sorry
winners that's what it comes down to it
they starting quarterback somebody say
that I don't like for whom Oh
the quarterback wins is the funniest
funniest thing so but I will be really
obnoxious if the Jets win yeah really
man so I'm sorry
great night 11 around 5:30 we'll be
there it is gonna be a good time we'll
be recording the podcast at 6:00 if you
want to come by we'll be handing out
free kuzey
Connors dad's gonna be there which is
just awesome screams okay he's gonna put
it out when I am Browns fans if you're
coming because I'm sure everyone's
selling their Jets tickets please come
to the tailgate we want fans yeah every
tailgate we want both fans way to LSU
fans in Austin they were [ __ ] crazy
they were I went from thinking I was
gonna fight that guy to thinking he was
my best friend he was I don't think
we've recapped any of this tailgate but
he
got into a fight what somebody else and
we actually went to help him out so even
if we're not fans of your team if you're
on the tailgate tour your sticky you're
one of us we will support you we've got
your and little known fact my fighter
flight is all fight I'd use I have not
been to a football game or bar in like
seven years where I didn't try to break
up a fight
true story so special guest referee
Maddy Middleton Maddy Mills roughing it
up baby that's not the Jersey I'll be
wearing Monday night but it will be a
special one we will see you guys there
from Ella O'Connor this is Matt don't
forget to subscribe on youtube subscribe
on Apple pods and Spotify and we will
yell at you guys
Tuesday morning live from MetLife
parking lot